okay let me talk to you now about maybe
the craziest proposal from Donald Trump
yet it has nothing to do with the
clothing that Melania would be forced to
or barred from wearing if she were to be
first lady that is not what I'm going to
talk to you about today it relates to
Trump's Muslim ban Donald Trump
initially proposed the Muslim ban it
then became a huge attention getter it
has attracted some of the most extreme
lunatics to the Trump campaign but it's
also been a real problem for Trump
because for example it would be
unconstitutional according to people who
understand the Constitution and Trump
has shifted on what exactly it would be
right first it was we're gonna ban
Muslim immigration period until we
figure out what the hell is going on
then it's a temporary travel ban for
Muslims from certain countries then it's
just for people from certain countries
regardless of whether they're Muslim or
not it's countries associated with
terror but which countries would be on
the list
we don't know completely unhinged
ridiculous unconstitutional idea so now
Donald Trump has decided to cap off I
would say the most inflammatory and
ignorant and pointless policy idea of
his entire campaign by saying he
wouldn't impose what he calls extreme
vetting a sort of ideological test on
people who want to come into the country
as immigrants the test would be met to
somehow confirm that people wanting to
come in share what Trump describes as
American values and it depends where in
the world you come from there would be
some parts of the world Louis where if
you want to come to the u.s. you're
exempt from the test now of course which
areas those are continues to be a
mystery but Donald Trump then talked
about this ideological test that these
immigrants would have to face here is
Donald Trump talking about this a little
bit now I'll warn you you might not
recognize Trump's delivery he is going
to be looking to his sides a lot and
speaking in a very bizarre cadence
that's because he's using a teleprompter
during this speech something he
criticizes other politicians for then
does himself but far worse than any of
the others do it take a look a Trump
administration will establish a clear
principle that will govern all decisions
pertaining to immigration and we will be
tough
and we will be even extreme extreme
we should only admit into this country
those who share our values and respect
our people in the Cold War yeah we had
an ideological screening test the time
is overdue to develop a new screening
test for the threats we face today I
call it extreme vetting I call it
extreme extreme vetting our country has
enough problems yeah we don't need more
and these are problems like we've never
had before one of the main problems is
trump so nominee in a major party I like
when he does the teleprompter thing he
shifts very dramatically from one side
all the way over to the other side to
look at his prompter screens his
prompter mirrors and it's very very
strange but because you might have been
distracted by his delivery I'm gonna put
up for you here Trump's immigrant and
ideology test so basically he said
number one we're only going to admit
those who share our values and respect
our people defined how totally
subjective absolutely meaningless number
two we're going to screen out members or
sympathizers of terrorist groups so what
you're just gonna ask them if they
sympathize with those groups couldn't
people just lie number three you're
gonna screen out anyone who has a
hostile attitude towards our country or
its principles does being against drone
warfare count as being hostile to one of
the principles of the US drone warfare
is a really big big thing now again
totally subjective we're going to screen
out anyone who believes that Sharia law
should supplant American law I predict
not many people would admit to that if
they're trying to get into the United
States they are going to screen out
anyone who doesn't believe in our
Constitution really I wonder if you
suggest banning people from the country
on the basis of religion would that
actually make you be barred from the
country under Trump's ideological test
because if so many of his own supporters
would be banned from the country and
lastly anyone who supports bigotry and
hatred well there goes a whole bunch of
Trump supporters right out right out the
window this is totally insane and the
craziest part he he reminisces
positively about when during the Cold
War we needed ideological tests you know
what Trump is talking about right are
you or have you ever been a member of
the Communist Party he is reminiscing
about going back to that time with some
tests that you're going to give in what
language will the test be given that's
that's one question right and of course
number two if these are evil people as
Trump described some of them to be don't
you think they would just be prepared to
lie on the ideological test yeah I'm not
sure what Donald Trump is trying to to
get across here yeah it's the idea that
he'll be tough it's the idea that he'll
keep all the terrorists out but if you
look at this plan in detail it doesn't
make much sense now the Netherlands what
they have when you apply for immigration
status is as we've discussed this video
that they show you right and the idea is
that well these are our values we have
values in this country and if this video
upsets you you might not be a good fit
right of course in this country we don't
even have a consensus about what those
values are no doubt yet this makes no
sense
it is absolutely the it's the lowest of
the low in capping off the most
ridiculous proposal from Trump other
than maybe punishing women who have
abortions and building a wall that
Mexico is not going to pay for that
would really not solve the immigration
situation that we have in the US Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
Tryon to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed comm slash TDPS
I don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like $300 for prescription
glasses hi which is just insane Warby
Parker glasses start at $95 that's what
mine cost and for every pair of glasses
sold Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker comm slash
TDP s it costs nothing